alors
[Musique]
j
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs hop
je vais vous remonte un peu la tête vous
êtes un peu de travers ça va vous allez
bien alors aujourd'hui bonne nouvelle
j'ai reçu à un samsung galaxy s 10 plus
samsung galaxy s 10 e on va en parler
alors on en parle aujourd'hui un peu
rapidement je suis curieux de voir
comment samsung nous a agencé ces boîtes
à l'intérieur petit unboxing prise en
main rapide ont gelé eu en main ya pas
très longtemps
lors de l'impact à londres si vous vous
souvenez j étais si vous souvenez pas je
vous met la vidéo
quelque part par là pour pouvoir aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil elle découle
très très cool ces smartphones sont cool
on va en reparler d'ici quelques jours
laissez moi le temps de les tester
tranquillement pour l'instant on fait un
homme boxing on regarde comment vous
avez fait à l'intérieur vous me direz
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire voici les galaxy s 10 plus
s10e alors j'ai pas trouvé intéressant
nécessairement de prendre le s10 bien
que ce soit le bon compromis qui peut le
plus peut le moins on va te regarder le
dise plus mais avant toute chose on va
jeter un coup d'oeil du côté du s10 eux
on arrive directement sur le smartphone
très très jolie smartphone comme d'adam
regarder on prend obtient la languette
il vient tout seul j'aime beaucoup le
format du et 10e je trouve vraiment
intéressant l'écran plat pas incurvé
petit format 5,8 pouces je trouve que
c'est bien réussi et au crawl la très
jolie très agréable beau boulot fait de
la part de samsung là dessus d'où le
module photo on retrouve un respect
qu'on va appeler les passes et
smartphones vraiment cool ici offre nous
avons de quoi éjecté votre petite carte
sim
à l'intérieur les guides de prise en
main bon ça je vous le passez en très
très rapidement il ya assez peu
d'intérêt on arrive ensuite de ce côté
là alors toujours très intéressant bloc
de charge
je sais pas si vous lisez bien
adaptative face charging donc
de charge rapide on un adaptateur usb
vers pu usb type c on retrouve là le
câble bon usb usb pour la recharge je
vous le passez aussi et là des petits
écouteurs signé à kg des écouteurs avec
une prise jack
car oui mesdames messieurs samsung a
toujours conservé sa prise directe sur
ses smartphones donc ça c'est
franchement cool secours trouvent à
l'intérieur c'est pas révolutionnaire
mais j'aime bien le boulot qui a été
fait par samsung
toujours très classe on sentit relief là
haut niveau du doigt bien papier recyclé
j'ai l'impression et j'aime beaucoup
cette couleur prisme blanc très bien
réussi alors ce smartphone on va les
tester dans quelques jours donc
abonnez-vous comme ça vous saurez tout
voici maintenant le galaxy s 10 plus
alors bon on garde la même typologie de
bois atteint l'âge et le modèle 128 gia
toujours avec ce petit relief sous le
doigt franchement ça marche c'est cool
alors voyez c'est ça c'est la même chose
à l'intérieur là j'ai la langue est où
je viens tirer et hop je sors cette
partie là et là j'arrive directement sur
le smartphone ça c'est intéressant c'est
une conception de boîte qui est un peu
différente mais je trouve ça mal et puis
c'est vrai que franchement l'exercice
viande boxing on se renouvelle pas
énormément relâche pour que pour le coup
samsung a vraiment fait son un bonne
conception comme ça au louvre d'un côté
de l'autre on a deux niveaux d'ouverture
bon là ça va être pareil le guide de
démarrage rapide de chorales tiroirs de
cap sinon ça on prend on laisse de côté
le smartphone en lui-même y en a neuf le
petit côté plastique là juste là côté
petit plastique je prends je tire ça
vient et franchement c'est vous j'ai
pris en couleur vert derrière
j'aime bien je trouve que lyès ça change
franchement par rapport à ce qu'on peut
trouver habituellement sur ce type aux
logiques produit on vient l'effeuiller
tout doucement à la on enlève tous
délicatement et avec amour
voilà là franchement on va pas se mentir
c'est quand même la grande classe alors
moi je reste un peu dubitatif sur ce
double module photo là à l'avant je
voulais déjà dit à très longtemps
lorsque ce projet a été énoncé je suis
encore dubitatifs aujourd'hui on va
regarder ça ensemble et on va voir si au
final il est en tout cas au niveau boîte
on a exactement la même chose vous vous
en douterez le bloc de recharge rapide
un adaptateur usb usb type c vos
écouteurs à kg et là votre câble
d'alimentation donc de ce point de vue
là franchement c'est exactement la même
chose
laissez-moi l'allumé au samsung galaxy s
10 là ça claque
la différence sur le s 10e c'est que au
niveau du bouton vous avez up la samsung
galaxy s 10 peu cool c'est que au niveau
du bouton vous avez si le capteur
d'empreintes digitales donc ça va être
différent configurer ça franchement
c'est aussi hyper cool avec les les deux
formats vous voyez ça n'a strictement
rien à voir
smartphone installé j'ai testé le
capteur d'empreintes digitales
je trouve que ça va pas trop mal c'est
pas le plus tôt que le plus rapide du
monde voyait up
j'appuie dessus 1 2 une seconde et demi
l'âge et le capteur d'empreinte digitale
au niveau de la tranche 1
voilà ça va beaucoup plus vite hop merci
beaucoup après ça joue franchement a pas
grand chose les deux sont très bons a
envoyé le format est vraiment différent
elles disent plus vous avez cet écran
incurvé le s10e vous avez cet écran plat
mais moi j'aime bien
si je compare par rapport aux pixels 3
que j'utilise en ce moment mais il ya
plus de place d'écran disponibles sur ce
format là je trouve vraiment bien alors
on va reparler tout ça d'ici quelques
jours
c'était histoire de vous les montrer
rapidement de les allumer on va vraiment
s'est testé de fond en comble on va
regarder tout ça en détail
et puis je vous donnerai mon retour
d'ici quelques jours c'est donc une
vidéo un petit peu courtes un peu bref
pour vous présenter les boîtes des
galaxy s 2 es10 plus j'aime bien
franchement je trouve que c'est vraiment
bien fait samsung maîtrise vraiment son
haut de gamme de a à z au niveau du
packaging jusqu'aux produits
j'ai trouvé très prometteur très
intéressant et après ce qui est malin
est ce qui me ferait presque oublier
c'est cette petite
une petite bulle là c'est le fait que ce
soit plus fondée sur le côté à voir si
je m'y habitue
ça va vraiment être le gros point
d'interrogation je ne doute pas que ce
smartphone soit performant rapide
à voir maintenant sur la photo nuit on
va comparer la photo de nuit par rapport
aux celui du pixel 3 qui pour l'instant
pour moi est vraiment celui qui déchire
le plus ample de nuit donc on va
comparer les deux on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours vous invite donc à vous
abonner comme ça vous saurez tout et
puis on va aller parler également de ce
smartphone là parce que a lieu
aujourd'hui même
ce soir moment vous regardez la vidéo en
tout cas si vous la regardez le jour de
sortie je vais tomber
attention un événement à paris justement
pour présenter ses s10 s10 plus est 10e
à paris où donc ça sera l'occasion d'en
parler avec d'autres personnes
journalistes influenceurs et d'avoir
leur retour donc restez connectés et si
vous voulez voir plus d'infos sur tous
les smartphones du moment je leur offre
du mwc j'ai vu plein de trucs hyper cool
vous invite à consulter ma playlist
comme ça vous saurez tout absolument
tout voilà où je vous embrasse à très
bientôt ciao